what did you say your name was again
Barry Allen listy smoke hey youtubers
it's Charlie this week on arrow we met
Barry Allen before he becomes the flash
who learned all about brother Bloods
Super Soldier Serum and Malcolm Merlyn
runs afoul of Ra's al Ghul since so much
happened I'm going to be doing my top 5
moments then my review and I'll be doing
a separate Q&A video just for the flash
so be sure to subscribe to get that also
remember this is just part one of a
two-part episode part two will be next
week
here we go top five moments number five
the references so see if you caught all
these the chemical shelf in the lab and
the sound of lightening was a reference
to the accident that created the first
Barry Allen flash in the comic books
Kord industries so the court industries
centrifuge that got stolen is actually a
reference to Ted Kord one of the many
people to become Blue Beetle in the
comic books he was like a wealthy
industrialist think of him is like a
nerdier version of Tony Stark the
particle accelerator so they were
talking about the particle accelerator
being turned on soon in the episode
think about the idea of how speed and
the flash work together and how that
intersects with the possibility of this
particle accelerator we haven't actually
seen it on the show yet but if we travel
there in the next episode you can bet
that is where Barry Allen is going to
get his Speed Force professor zoom when
Barry tells Oliver about how his mother
died and it looked like this human
tornado that's a reference to professor
zoom who in the comic books travelled
back in time to try and hurt Barry by
killing his mother Argus the Argus
bunker were all the sedatives for the
super soldiers are being stored is a
reference to Argus that Amanda Waller
controls
remember they're an organization like
shield that helps out superheroes Nanda
Parbat Malcolm Merlyn references the
home of the League of Assassins leading
Mora to contact them and let Ra's al
Ghul know that Malcolm is still alive my
number four favorite moment is all the
stunts so especially that first stunt
where Oliver gets kicked out of the car
by the super soldier he gets kicked out
of the car with the door ouch that's
gonna hurt number three Barry inflows to
these scenes so in case you missed it
arrow the show itself is shipping them
hard it was so funny how Felicity just
automatically dumped the thought of even
liking Oliver the minute Barry showed an
interest in her there is definitely some
sexy time for them in the future
how about that conversation they had
about penetration though number two
Felicity brings
area to the arrowcave so berry is
officially on Team arrow now obviously
he's got to help Oliver in the next
episode but think about it you have two
members of the Justice League already
all you need now is a cow a golden lasso
some Oreos and a red cape and you're
there and my number one moment Barry
Allen heir to the Speed Force the only
person on earth that's faster than
Superman unless you can't professor zoom
I thought the introduction of Barry was
so awesome especially the soundtrack
they used to the imagery of the train
when he walks into frame the pouring
rain droplets obviously he's probably
going to be zooming in between those in
the next episode and almost every line
of dialogue he had was a teaser for his
destiny as the flash but let me know
what your favorite moment was and if you
saw any references that I missed be sure
to write them in the comments overall I
really loved the episode I give it an A+
just for being so much fun and for them
being so bold with the DC Universe
references I love how arrow isn't afraid
to go into the comic books like a lot of
other shows like agents of shield kinda
are the writers said they paid special
attention to this being a story about
the flash inside of arrows world and not
being like this backdoor pilot like a
flash episode sandwiched between two
arrow episodes and I really love that
they did that one of my favorite parts
of the episode that it didn't mention
during my top five was actually the
music so if you remember that first
scene between Barry and Felicity it's
almost like there's Christmas music
playing in the background
almost like arrow is giving you this
early Christmas present wrapped and red
wrapping paper
don't open it too fast let me know what
you thought about the episode though
remember next week is part two he'll be
getting his powers in that episode I'm
also doing a special Q&A video just for
the flash it's called ask emergency it's
gonna be a new weekly show that I'll be
doing so be sure and leave your
questions about the flash the spin-off
show and how he's going to work on arrow
and I'll answer those in that video
right now you can click here to get that
video I'll add the annotation as soon as
I post it early in the morning and you
can click here to get my arrow video
from last week thanks so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
morning super fast high five
you